we've lost any real focus on human
flourishing so we don't even notice how
good the world is and when we talk about
say polar bears right
i love polar bears they're actually my
favorite animal but it's crazy that we
talk about polar bears like this polar
brass to move from one piece of ice to
another and that should make us cry but
three billion people with no energy
nobody cares at all
you're a philosopher what are you doing
talking about fossil fuels
yeah it's kind of an interesting thing i
don't know a lot of people who follow me
probably not most people have seen this
clip where i'm
in uh testifying in front of the senate
in front of barbara boxer and i'm from
california so she's my senator
and i give this whole presentation
explaining why i think that
some of the then obama administration's
policies were in the wrong direction
and she just like dismisses all of that
and she just asked me mr mr epstein
that's how she pronounced my name are
you are you a scientist and i said no
i'm a philosopher and she said oh well
you know why do we have a philosopher
and i said it's to teach you how to
think more clearly
and that's really how i how i think
about it i mean my
so my background is actually i sort of
was an aspiring tech entrepreneur
until i was 20 i sort of went to very
elite math science computer science high
school i was when i went to duke that's
what i was planning on being a tech
entrepreneur
and actually fell in love with
philosophy because i found that for me
it was the most practical
subject because philosophy deals you can
think of it as three things it deals
with our methods
our assumptions and our values and we
could go into any of those and we may
end up mentioning all of them but all
three of those things are fundamental to
uh every kind of thought process uh
that exists so for example like the
world is obsessed with renewable energy
why is the world obsessed with renewable
energy instead of say cost effective
energy or even low carbon energy why
renewable
and i would argue that's ultimately a
value issue people think there's a
certain value
in doing something that can be repeated
over and over and over again
or something that is sort of drawing on
more supposedly natural forces like the
sun and the wind
versus digging stuff up from the ground
that's that's a moral issue
a value issue that's not an issue of
it's not like a scientific issue
but people think it's a scientific issue
and so it doesn't strike most people as
bad that we oppose
nuclear even though that's a non-carbon
source of energy that i believe is much
more promising than solar winds it's
just one example among many
of how methods assumptions and values
shape
everything and so my goal was to be a
practical philosopher
and so for the first seven years of my
career i just wrote about everything and
i was just trying to apply philosophy to
help people think more clearly about
every issue so it was like cloning
foreign policy
uh the economy and then with energy
i it was the first thing that i really
wanted to become an expert in
and i think the thing that appealed to
me about it was this is the industry
that powers every other industry so sort
of like philosophy is the science that
guides every other science and i do
think of philosophy as a science like
energy is the industry that powers every
other industry and so our thinking about
energy affects uh everything so if we
make a decision you know that doubles
the price of oil
like that has ramifications for
everything in the world because energy
is what powers our machines
and our machines are what accomplish
just about all the productive work that
exists in the world so that's that's
why i got interested in it and why i
think philosophy has to deal with energy
in general and then
how we think about fossil fuels in
particular you talk about
the fact that the fossil fuels climate
change
debate has a lot of actors contributing
to it
from physicists to climatologists to
meteorologists to the numbers people
to the policy makers and quite rightly
that thing about if you're in a dark
room trying to touch an elephant and you
could feel different bits of it
no one really has that entire
perspective
is there a role on both sides of this
debate do you think for someone to come
in
like yourself who is perhaps an
all-rounder and can
start to pull together what all of this
means as opposed to just looking very
narrow and deep within one domain
yeah i mean i you know i'm biased but i
think so and i think so in two different
respects so one is just with any
interdisciplinary question
where nobody is going to be a specialist
in all the different
elements if you just think of the issue
of climate i mean it clearly involves or
should clearly involve
things like you know just all the
physical things related to how rising
co2
levels affect the global climate system
but then because the rising co2 levels
come from using fossil fuels
it it involves all of our economy it
involves energy economics questions like
can solar and wind actually replace what
fossil fuels do that kind of thing so
it's clearly an interdisciplinary
question so you need
you need some sort of generalist who has
hopefully good judgment
to then survey the relevant experts and
decide
you know or at least make a good
judgment you know what's the best thing
so i think that's true and i do try to
do that
i think the more important thing though
that people don't understand
is that it's very possible for almost
everybody to be thinking incorrectly
about an issue and so i just want to
summarize very quickly why i think
almost everyone thinks
incorrectly about the issue of climate
and this is independent of what the
scientific facts happen to be so i'll
try to make this quick but i think it's
important like
i think there are three principles of
thinking about our impact on climate
that almost everyone will agree with but
almost nobody uses
and so that's always an interesting
situation where everyone agrees that
it's right if if presented to them but
nobody uses it so one
is that we should think of what we call
climate change or i'd say climate impact
we should think of it as a side effect
of fossil fuel use so just like i think
you know i decided to take a covered 19
vaccine i evaluate the benefits and the
side effects
you need to do that with everything so
when you're thinking of climate impacts
you need to not just think of the
climate impacts and certainly not just
the negative ones you need to think of
the benefits that come along with them
so that's one principle
and i think that's pretty flagrantly
violated people just say like oh let's
listen to the scientists by which they
mean climate scientists but they don't
talk about the benefits of fossil fuels
but obviously we should
the second thing because we need to not
look only at the benefits of fossil
fuels in general
we need to look at the benefits of
fossil fuels that specifically
neutralize climate danger and can
neutralize the negative potential
impacts of rising co2 so
you know when i take a covet 19 vaccine
it has some side effects
yeah pretty minor in my experience and i
think most people's but
you still have those side effects the
the vaccine itself doesn't
cure its own side effects right and
that's true with antibiotics and other
things but what's interesting about
fossil fuels
is they do often cure their own side
effects because what fossil fuels are
providing
is energy and energy allows us to use
machines
to produce value for us and so you see
in the issue of climate
we can use let's say let's say rising
co2 levels caused some challenge with
drought
okay but fossil fuels also power the
machines
that alleviate drought so you have to
factor that in and when you look at the
last hundred years it's really
interesting because over the last
century if you tally how many people are
dying
from climate-related disasters like
extreme temperatures drought
uh wildfire storms floods those are down
98
so that's really astounding like your
your likelihood of dying from a climate
related disaster is one
fiftieth of what it used to be despite
rising co2 levels for the last 100 plus
years so that either means that the
rising co2 levels haven't done any net
damage
or that they have sort of been a net
negative but the positive of what i call
climate mastery from fossil fuels has
far far
outweighed it so when you're when we're
thinking we have to look at the benefits
but specifically the climate mastery
benefits
and then the third thing and this really
brings up the issue of values
is when we're looking at the climate
impacts of fossil fuels we cannot assume
that they are mostly oral negative let
alone catastrophic we're certainly open
to that possibility
but we need to be open to positive
neutral and negative impacts and so one
example that i found very revealing
because i didn't even think about it
before i started studying this is the
obvious phenomenon of the fertilizer
effect
which is that when we put more co2 in
the atmosphere uh
you have a lot more plant growth and
it's really astounding how much global
greening there has been that can be
directly attributed to rising co2
and in the history of the planet it kind
of makes sense because we're at about
we're less than one-tenth the historical
high of co2 and a lot of the history
the history of life on this planet where
life really flourished
was when you had plants big enough to
feed dinosaurs and they needed a lot
more co2
than we could possibly provide so that
doesn't mean it's all good it just means
we cannot have the bias
that it's bad even with warmth we can't
have the bias that it's bad it turns out
cold related deaths
uh exceed heat related deaths by a
factor of 15.
and in general and everyone every
climate scientist will agree with this
in general the way global warming works
is it warms mostly places that are the
colder more polar regions of the earth
it warms more during the colder seasons
like winter and it warms more at night
which are generally the times we want
warmth so it's not to say it can't cause
negatives but we have to be open to
positive neutral and negatives and what
i see with climate is people have this
assumption that
if we impact climate it's it's wrong
it must be a disaster and we should
immediately get rid of fossil fuels and
i i think that's ultimately a real
kind of a moral and ultimately religious
assumption i think that the root of all
of
what i call climate catastrophe and
we'll go into the details but is not
that there's actually an existential
catastrophe for
human beings i don't think there's any
evidence of that i do think we impact
the climate
a significant amount but i think it's
based on this idea that it's immoral for
us to impact the climate
and when we do something we think is
immoral we expect it to be bad it's a
lot like religion where
if you you know if you do the wrong
thing like if you violate the
commandments
then you go to hell and i think that
that the whole global warming climate
catastrophe
is really kind of a secularized
religious uh
hell narrative because i think if you
look at the benefits of the fossil fuels
the climate mastery benefits and you
actually look at the impacts
i don't even think you can show the
impacts the climate impacts on their own
or net negative i don't think anyone can
prove that
let alone that they're so bad that we
should do without the energy
that billions of us use to to flourish
and that billions more
need can you sink into that a little bit
more the perfect planet premise i think
you call it
yeah and sometimes i call it the the
delicate nurture premise
and i think of it as just so you get
that i call the overall thing the uh the
anti-impact framework and so you can
summarize the anti-impact framework as
it's more it's intrinsically immoral for
us to
uh impact nature significantly and then
it's it's
uh inevitably self-destructive and so
delicate nurture perfect planet deals
with inevitably self-destructive so
if we have significant impact on nature
then somehow it's going to come back to
bite us and delicate nurture is the idea
that nature in its unimpacted state so
before we start allegedly screwing it up
is a sufficient safe and stable delicate
balance and so you can see this in
something like
uh you know the lion king which i don't
wanna which i like a lot as a movie in a
lot of ways but
you know they talk about at the
beginning you know the delicate balance
and the circle of life
and you have this idea that kind of
everything is in harmony
and then if you disrupt that then
everything is going to sort of
uh go to hell and this is not at all
this is
unfortunately passes as a scientific
view but this is not a scientific view
this is just a faith-based view because
there's no evidence for this at all
if you look at the history of the planet
including human beings
what you see is nature is not sufficient
safe and stable
it is deficient uh dangerous and dynamic
it's that that's why our average life
expectancy historically
is 30. the planet is not a very
nourishing place
it's not a very safe place and so what
happens is most of our lives are just
spent
trying to find some kind of nourishment
some sort of protection from all of
nature's dangers
with very little opportunity for the
kind of fulfillment that you study
uh on your show and it's only once
we figure out not only how to use tools
to make ourselves more productive
but how to use tools that have non-human
sources of energy because
we're very weak ourselves once we can
make these tools that have non-sources
of energy
namely machines that's when we live in
an amazing world when machines
can do work for us like the combine
harvester that can do 700 times more
work more reaping and threshing of wheat
than the best
manual labor and i think of the world
today as as i think of it as an amazing
place i think of an amazing place for
human beings
and i think it all comes down to
machines because if you look at every
all the amazing value in our world that
did not exist 200 years ago
it falls into one of three categories
usually more either
is a machine you know like my washing
machine or the heating machines or the
cooling machines like that makes me
super comfortable
or it's produced by a machine like my
whole house is produced
by machines like hundreds of machines
ultimately or
it's produced by time freed up by
machines you think of like what both of
us do for a living like that's only
possible
because machines allow us to produce the
basics so easily
that we can have jobs like practical
philosopher and you know modern wisdom
expert or whatever your exact thing is
and so i people tend to think of today's
world
as bad and i think of it as it's not
perfect but it's i think it is an
amazing world where we have
machine laborers like serving us
and making our lives amazing and so much
of what we experience as like the
stability of things
is only the stability of having mass
machine labor
that you do not experience nature as
stable if you live in nature
draw the line for me between
energy and that well-being then the more
energy that we produce
the more machines that we can fuel and
the
greater the human flourishing is that
the basic premise yeah and so one way
i've come up with to explain this is
what i call the private jet
problem so i'll just speak for myself
i cannot unfortunately afford to travel
via private chat mean you both
a lot um and why can't i we have all the
technology right
we know how to do it but it's not cost
effective
as in the value most people can get from
it
is not worth all the value that they
need to put into it including
uh human time so let's say you know
private jet round trip
costs 50 grand well maybe it saves me
five hours total or ten hours total
but i don't i can't make enough money to
justify that whereas tim cook can right
it's total or warren buffett like warren
buffett has a private jet called the
indefensible
but it's not indefensible because his
time is so valuable so for him
a private jet is cost effective but for
most of us it isn't and
one thing to notice about the modern
world is it's a very rare phenomenon
that a life-giving machine is not cost
effective you take like a washing
machine
a washing machine is cost effective now
washing machine
it does take human time and resources to
make it possible because we have to
build it
and we have to provide the fuel the
energy to operate it
but we figured out how to do so with
little enough human time and resources
where most of us can afford it although
there are billions of people who can't
and that's why i say we need even more
cost-effective energy so the idea is
that
the more cost-effective machine labor is
the more the more we can benefit from
machines when it's not cost effective it
doesn't matter if it exists
we can't uh benefit from it just like in
previous generations you know
people like kings had a lot of our
modern standard of living not all of it
but
a lot of it but it wasn't cost-effective
to provide it required basically
abusing human beings as machines so
cost-effective machine labor is like the
key to everything and the key to
cost-effective machine labor
is cost-effective energy because the
energy is the food
for the machines and and it's one way we
just want to make sure
so you think of the private jet it's not
just the fuel of the private jet
although that is very expensive and
that's a big variable
you have to think what made the private
jet and the private jet was ultimately
made by thousands of different machines
if you think about the machines that
mined for the materials and processed
the materials and transported them
and manufactured them etc etc so if you
think of every machine that we have
as the product of thousands of machines
that machine not only uses the
energy it operates on but the machine
the energy the thousands of machines
operated on to make it and so you get
this idea that the cost of energy
determines the cost of everything so if
we have
energy that is super cost effective and
i think of it as
it's low cost it's on demand it's
versatile so it can power every kind of
machine
and it's on a global scale of billions
of people in thousands of places
if you can produce energy with that kind
of ultra cost effectiveness
then you have billions of people who can
benefit from the miracle
of machine labor but if you double
triple quadruple the price of energy
then more and more of our amazing
machines become like
private jets so it's inaccessible this
sounds great
it sounds yeah i i want modern world
with loads of things done for me so that
i can spend time on myself
but you haven't talked about any of the
externalities and there's this
many many many stats and many people who
are probably part of the green movement
who are listening now
who are thinking yeah yeah that's great
alex but the
acidification of the oceans and the
melting of the ice caps and the polar
bears are losing their homes and we're
polluting and there's smog and 97 of
climate scientists say that climate
change is real
what how can you lay out
some some insights to do with fossil
fuels externalities
that might surprise people sure i mean
it come and there's also you know the
other thing they'll raise is well can't
we do it without fossil fuels so we can
talk about that
as well like let's not use fossil fuels
let's use these um
other sources which i'd be in favor of
if if you could in favor of anything
that's that's better but if yeah we talk
about
what's called the externalities the
first thing i want to observe about this
whole
externalities perspective is it is it
violates the
the principles that i talked about uh at
the beginning so when people are talking
about
the externalities that's a that's kind
of a technical way
and it's the negative externalities
notice that's a technical way
of saying we're going to ignore the
benefits and we're just going to focus
on
uh the negative side effects if you
think of the positive externalities of
fossil fuels like take something like
the existence of the modern internet
like when we were when people were
paying for
coal in the 1970s and 1980s which
provided the vast majority of
electricity
so people say oh that has a negative
externality because it puts co2 in the
atmosphere and that's causing warming
and we can talk about the consequence of
that
but what about the positive externality
of all of the time
and machines freed up for innovation
that made possible the internet
and then all the things the internet has
made possible in terms of medicine and
just think about like how many people
are alive right now with something like
covet 19 because of the internet because
of the knowledge that's disseminated
because of you know the rapid ability to
develop an mrna
a vaccine like all of that came from the
coal industry
and yet all of these so-called
economists i mean they are economists
but i think they're they have the same
kinds of prejudices as everyone else
philosophically so they're so focused on
the negative externalities
they can't see uh the positive
externalities there's also i'll try to
make this point quickly there's kind of
a technical point
about externalities that some people
might be interested in um
externalities is like the basic idea of
externalities is that certain kinds of
negatives and actually positives
aren't reflected in the price of the
thing and so then if some economist or
economist king should like manipulate
the prices
but there's a core reason this is a
really bad idea because that assumes
that the price of the thing
reflects the value of the thing but the
prices of things
don't reflect the value of things they
reflect the value that very
that certain people they reflect the
minimum value of things to people like
you wouldn't pay it
if it wasn't worth it to you but you
think about oil like
when my life gets if i get pulled by a
helicopter to a hospital
what was that oil worth to me was that
worth three dollars a gallon
no i would pay whatever i have right so
part of what's going on with ignoring
the benefits of fossil fuels with this
kind of pseudo-scientific
pseudo-economic externality thing
is we're ignoring the fact that the
value we get from fossil fuels
is far far greater than the price we pay
from fossil fuels which is not the same
say compared to like barbie dolls
although for some people you know that
may be their life
so there's all of these dynamics that
are causing people to ignore the truth
that the benefit we get from fossil
fuels far
far outweighs the side effects and then
the other thing there i
would point out so i think of it as
let's just say i'm right and we'll talk
about in a minute
that there is no near-term replacement
for fossil fuels so that to have this
ultra-cost-effective energy that's
low-cost on-demand
versatile global scale like there's no
other way to do it without fossil fuels
i can prove that later but
like if i'm right then to justify
restricting fossil fuel use in a world
where three billion people have
virtually no energy and three billion
more have amounts of energy you and i
would consider completely unacceptable
like you would need to prove like a
total cataclysm
from co2 to justify depriving people of
energy energy is that
important so i think that's how we
should go into the question of side
effects and the fact that
99.9 of people including climate
scientists don't look at it that way
they don't look at us oh fossil fuels
make our world possible
including they make it livable as we
know it including we're only as safe
from climate
as we are because of fossil fuels that
just shows that there's this whole bias
against against the benefits and only
looking at the side effects and then if
you look at the side effects
you need to really look at them from a
human perspective are they
bad and you need to be precise about
them you need to look for positive
neutral and negative so
you know you went through various things
like uh the polar bears is one where you
know the populations are growing
and in some ways in a way that's
dangerous to people and so one thing
that's kind of dishonest is people
ignore that narrative like they brought
up polar bears when it seemed like they
were going to shrink but then when they
did it nobody brought them up
like oh i'm so happy i'm so ha like al
gore there's this meme like
you know when al gore was born there
were only 7 000 polar bears now only 40
000 remain
you know that kind of thing so there's
just this whole bias um
so i forget the other categories you you
you brought up like
so a city acidification of the seas
coral reefs being destroyed okay let's
deal with that one so acidification so
this is
interesting term for a supposedly
scientific movement
acid has a very definite meaning on the
ph scale so it's like lower than
seven so seven is neutral you know above
seven is alkaline or basic
and so you're talking about the oceans
going from about 8.2 to 8.1 so you
should call it neutralization
uh not acidification so it's used to
like act like oh it's
acid um and so there's a real question
of
why do we expect that going from 8.2 to
8.1
is going to be a catastrophe at all let
alone that justifies depriving billions
of people
uh of energy why do we think that way
and i think part of it is
we don't i mean to the value issue i
don't think we value human life and
human flourishing enough in these things
so we can talk about that but definitely
it's a delicate nurture premise the idea
that oh the ocean that we inherited
was this perfect delicate balance and if
anything changes in the ph
everything is going to go to hell if you
just look at the history of the planet
this makes absolutely no sense because
the oceans were much more neutral in the
past
when you had explosions of life ocean
species deal with
much more dramatic shifts in the ph than
we're talking about they don't it's like
temperature
you don't deal with one temperature you
don't deal with one ph you deal with a
range
so a shift in temperature is a shift in
the range and the shift in ph the shift
in the range
and also some of the most prolific seas
in the world are the
are the closest to neutral in the world
so i think it really is coming from this
philosophical or religious perspective
that we expect it to be bad
and then where scientists fit in is you
can have like selective science where
the government says hey i really want
to see some negative consequences of
fossil fuels can you what can you show
me in the ocean
and of course there are going to be a
bunch of negative consequences in the
ocean
i mean even real ones right any change
is going to have certain kinds of
negatives
but the question is are you getting the
full picture and is this anything on the
level
that we should be considered depriving
people of energy
is it even possible that it's on the
level of the amount of benefit we get
from global greening on the land which
nobody wants to talk about so notice
they only want to talk about the things
that are negative about fossil fuels and
not positive and they have no concern
about depriving billions of people of a
of a modern life so i forget what other
examples you brought up but that's
another one too where you can see i just
want to point out
it's like the philosophy and the
framework is
guiding this and it's distorting science
so there are a lot of people
doing good science on this but that only
works if
you're asking people to really give you
positive and negative neutral side
effects
and then if you integrate those with the
benefits oh the one other thing to say
about the ocean stuff is
why do we care about ocean acidification
so-called why do we care about it like
presumably a big part of it is because
we want a prolific ocean
that we can get food from i like seafood
a lot of people like seafood
well from a human flourishing
perspective the natural ocean
is a desert it's a lot of the how
prolific the ocean is is actually
related to our activities and our waste
that's why
that's one reason why you have a lot of
marine thriving
what do you mean your coastlines well
just because they
like you think about the ocean like the
ocean has it's it's a lot like an
actual desert it's just like there are
certain things that are needed in the
ocean like
like uh iron in order to make these
different kinds of plankton
that you know it's got this whole food
chain but a lot of the lower elements of
that
are benefit from certain kinds of uh
byproducts of our civilization because
you need that to make the food
but the real point is if we know that
the ocean is a desert
why don't we actively try to improve it
and there's what's called
aquaculture which is usually you know
that's like making modern salmon which
you see people
vehemently oppose because they think
it's wrong to impact nature
and even more exciting that there's
what's called mariculture so mariculture
is thinking of how do you sort of enrich
a large portion of the ocean
so that a lot more food up here so they
did this there is an experiment with
this uh
native tribe in canada and this guy name
i think his name was russ george
they're the haida tribe and they
basically put a bunch of iron in a
certain part of the ocean and they just
had this unbelievable
proliferation of salmon it was just it
was great and it made sense because the
iron was the limiting factor it was the
bottleneck
in terms of you know plankton and other
things existing
in that in that place and yet
was this celebrated did people say hey
let's just do this like
even if there are some negatives on the
ocean hey let's let's
let's make the ocean bloom no the whole
modern environmental movement
had no interest in this and in fact they
were very critical like one of the main
climate catastrophist naomi klein she
was very critical and she like described
it as i don't like this all-you-can-eat
buffet that we've made and
it she said it was bad because whales
were coming to this bloom
and it was unnatural so it's like wait
do you care about the whales
or you you want them to die of natural
causes versus live of human causes so
again it reveals this very i call this
the anti-impact framework it's the
anti-human impact framework so the idea
that
everything we do to nature is immoral
and it must it must be self-destructive
and that dogma is just influencing
anything so if you actually care about
the oceans
from any kind of human perspective let's
keep using fossil fuels and then let's
see how we can engineer the oceans
to be far more prolific than they are
right now and let's get
let's improve this ocean desert does
this
fear of impacting nature and the perfect
planet premise and the other structures
that you've given us does that explain
why if what you're saying is true almost
no one talks about it
i'm not hearing politicians campaign on
it
i'm not on on which what on any pro
fossil fuel
talking points why is that the case it
why is it that
fossil fuels are so demonized is it just
is it all explained by the perfect
planet premise the fact that
humans are destroying mother nature and
it's kind of
across a multiple a few different
streams at the moment it seems almost
cool to be human hating
to be whatever the opposite of
anthropocentric is like anthropo
something else some other versions they
would call it biocentric although that's
okay yeah yeah because it's a tricky
thing to even isolate
because it's a specific anti-humanism
like i call it
human racism sometimes because like
everything the human race does is bad
and everything because why do you think
that is
just generally at the moment what is
this ambient
pervasive human racism that we're seeing
across
not just the environmental movement but
a lot of things at the moment
well i think if you look at the history
of it it you know it really started
emerging
in the 60s and 70s in turn like if you
look at the kind of environmental
philosophy
of even let's say the pioneers of the
greenhouse effect or not the pioneer
discoverers who discovered that if we
put morsi into the atmosphere it should
have a warming influence like
they were generally optimistic about
what that would mean and they talked
about like oh yeah i mean more plant
growth and
we'll be able to grow crops in siberia
and won't that be great
so it's interesting that you see how
much the philosophy shapes things
and you know ralph waldo emerson used to
call coal like portable climate like the
idea was yeah climate isn't very good
naturally but we can make it
artificially good or unnaturally good
through energy
in the 60s and 70s you have this idea
that it's wrong to impact nature and
it's inevitably self-destructive i mean
this is a primitive religious idea it's
been
around forever but in terms of having
cultural dominance it's really in the
60s and 70s
and i think a lot of the reason it's it
and it was it was spread in very
calculated ways throughout
the throughout the educational system
and then throughout the media system and
if you ask
well and alt and throughout the
political system and if you ask like why
then
i think a big part of it and there's a
great book uh by ein rand
my favorite philosopher called the new
left the anti-industrial revolution and
she was living through it and commenting
on it
and there was very explicitly it was
very explicit that the anti-capitalist
left needed a new cause as communism was
collapsing
and once the vietnam war was over the
vietnam war was a whole mess that
you know sort of beside the point but
that was like their issue then the
vietnam war was over
and they very they said explicitly like
let's make
our issue that capitalism destroys quote
the environment because they had their
their previous issue was capitalism
destroys the worker it destroys
productivity socialism will make us
productive
that didn't work out well at all like
everyone starved in the communist
countries
so iran made this point that the the
anti-capitalist side could either choose
to
embrace if they really valued production
they could embrace capitalism
or if it wasn't if opposing capitalism
wasn't really about production
they would find a new reason to oppose
capitalism and the reason they found is
capitalism quote destroys the
environment now
this is not at all true because if you
think about like you look at the
environment of us the soviet union or of
north korea like it's horrible in part
because it's
a lot of it hasn't the natural
environment hasn't been neutralized
enough but also they just pollute all
over the place
because they have no property rights in
general what leads to good environments
of all kinds is property rights because
people protect
what they own and they have wealth to
clean up their environment etc etc
but there were certain abuses in the u.s
environment and european environments
that people could point to and say hey
look you know this lake
can catch fire this city has more air
pollution than we would want
and i think a big mistake that the
pro-capitalism side made as they didn't
own that issue they didn't say no we're
for a really good environment for human
beings like we like clean air and clean
water
and productivity like capitalism is
where you can have it all
instead they seeded that to the
anti-capitalist side and so the
anti-capitalist side
started identifying with environment
but it wasn't at the core it wasn't
really about clean air and clean
water it was about eliminating our
impact on nature but those two got
blended together so if you look at the
idea of green
green means minimizing our impact but
what does that mean does that mean that
we don't build washing machines that we
don't build
roads that we don't build factories or
does it mean that we don't senselessly
destroy natural
beauty or senselessly pollute things
like i'm in favor of not
of not senselessly destroying things and
and not senselessly polluting
but i want roads and factories and all
of these things
and so but they blended together like
either you're for the environment which
lumps together
like you're for being green which lumps
together
like impacts on nature that are good and
in nature they're bad for us or you just
sort of hate the environment you're not
green and
part of my own mission was to give a
pro-human alternative to the
to the green movement so i think of it
as the human flourishing movement
where we're for human flourishing which
means a good environment for human
beings but that means we very highly
value production and intelligently
impacting nature we don't worship nature
we enhance we optimize we improve nature
so you can love nature but realize it's
very deficient
on its own so it needs to be
dramatically engineered
and enhanced and i think that that will
have appeal and i think it is growing in
terms of my own
my own movement and my own following but
it's the other side is so entrenched
and they constantly want us to think
that if you want a good environment
you have to be in sync with all of these
anti-industrial causes and
what's notable is they've always had
some reason why industry is bad
particularly fossil fuels are bad so
first it was we're going to run out of
fossil fuels
then it's oh they're going to make the
atmosphere just totally polluted
then it's catastrophic global cooling
then it's catastrophic global warming
there's never any change in the
certainty that fossil fuels the core of
capitalist civilization
is going to lead to some disaster we
just don't know which one
and so what that reveals is it's again
this delicate nurture idea if we're
impacting things a lot
it must be it must be bad and these
people are so i mean i'm talking about
the leaders now
they're so blind to how good the world
is the stat i think is most revealing is
when i was born in 1980
42 percent of the world lived on less
than two dollars a day like think about
that
less than two dollars a day so it's like
750 800
a year like that is nothing and now it's
less than 10
so 4 out of 10 people are in this
desperate poverty now just
40 41 years later it's less than 1 out
of 10.
this is the world is such a much so much
better place for those people
and nobody talks about it and so this
shows how powerful philosophy is
because our whole philosophy today is
dominated by minimal impact let's not
change nature
we've lost any real focus on human
flourishing so we don't even notice how
good
the world is and when we talk about say
you're talking about polar bears right
i love polar bears they're actually my
favorite animal but it's crazy that we
talk about polar bears like this polar
brass to move from one piece of ice to
another and that's
that should make us cry but three
billion people with no energy nobody
cares at all
about and as i tell in moral case for
fossil fuels like
what that means if you haven't ever
lived it or seen it i mean i tell a
story about
like a young woman who has a baby and
where we live
they'd have the baby would have an
incubator it's a premature baby that
incubator would be fine you wouldn't
even remember it a few months
later but there they don't have a live
electricity so that that baby just
dies and you see this this tragedy of
lack of energy is happening
everywhere around the world to billions
of people
and nobody cares because our philosophy
has told us
to care about minimizing our impact on
nature instead of maximizing
human flourishing you talk
you give a timeline in the book of these
cassandras
the people who make particular
predictions i'm just laughing because
that's my girlfriend's name
too sorry cassandra um not like that at
all
you know what i mean though right you
talk about in the 70s this is predicted
in 20 years time 20 years time rolls
around and
still not there okay now there's a new
problem now there's a new problem now
there's a new problem
some of the people that are listening
will be thinking right this sounds great
but we've got renewable energy we know
that
solar and wind and hydro are
potentials that will be able to replace
what we're using at the moment
why why can't we just do that
well i think it's it's those points need
to be looked at independently so first
of all with the
the cassandras or cassandras i think
it's important they're not that because
they're wrong
like the original cassandra cassandra my
girlfriend's cassandra i forget what
they're she's going to come in
if she's somewhere near she's going to
say is he is that like shouting me honey
what do you want
she's been she's been warned that i'm on
a on a podcast
uh she'll be happy that she she got a
shout out about 20 times yeah
exactly exactly so um yeah they haven't
been right whereas the original
cassandra was right that's the idea like
if someone write who wasn't being
listened to versus somebody whose voice
is the boy who cried wolf
which is much more except we still don't
and but interesting that people think oh
the wolf is finally coming so there's
that whole thing
that so that that people have been
totally wrong about fossil fuels
causing a catastrophe in fact fossil
fuels have made life much
better that's kind of one thing and then
there's another thing of okay
can we do the same things with
uh that we do with fossil fuels can we
do those with alternatives that's some
certainly something worth exploring but
you have to be clear are we exploring it
from the perspective of
life is amazing let's make it even
better with potential supplements or
substitutes
or is it no fossil fuels are going to
end the world so we need to just drop
everything
and sacrifice everything and just come
up with some crash scheme
to replace with alternatives so i think
that that's why i say they're
independent and i think
there is no evidence at all despite what
people say that from a human flourishing
perspective there's anything resembling
a catastrophe
and i think the path of fossil fuels is
um
is that they're going to keep making
making life better and better
but let's say somebody is not convinced
that they think i'm at least seriously
concerned
about future rises in co2 levels and i
haven't given you enough evidence here
not to be so that's that's a plausible
thing co2 is different from other
emissions because co2 aggregates in the
atmosphere so like if you have smog it
just disappears from the atmosphere it
doesn't build up over time
but co2 does build up over time so we
had a little less than .03 percent of
the atmosphere before we started using
fossil fuels and now we're a little
above
0.04 percent we could easily go to 0.05
percent or beyond
and there is a greenhouse effect so we
can expect a warming impact there's a
question of
of how much and we can expect that to
have other impacts
for various reasons i don't think those
will even be negative at all on balance
but
let's say you're very concerned about
that i respect that
it is legitimate to look at alternatives
but if we go back to the philosophy
you need to look at alternatives from a
human flourishing perspective so that
means you want
energy that's cost effective and if
you're concerned about co2 you want it
that's
low or almost no co2 there's actually
nothing with no co2
today because fossil fuels well here's
part of the challenge fossil fuels don't
just provide electricity which we have
the most alternatives for
they also provide heat and so
residential heat and particularly
industrial heat which is very high
levels of heat
and that's very hard to provide cost
effectively with electricity that's why
the most cost-effective thing for home
heating is natural gas
and for industrial heating is often
natural gas and it's pretty staggering
price differential so
so much of our society is based on just
directly burning fossil fuels
for industrial heat and then there's
heavy duty transportation where there's
no replacement for fossil fuels
for a while like you're talking about
cargo ships
and planes and all these things i mean
everything people are talking about is
not even close to
you know any reasonable prototype let
alone commercialization so
this points out to it is a real [ __ ] if
you
if you if you had a crisis or anything
resembling a crisis with fossil fuels
like
you would view that as a tragic
situation because fossil fuels are so
good and if you had to somehow figure
out a near-term replacement like
that would be so daunting and so
upsetting and the fact that people
aren't upset about it just shows they
don't really value
they don't value the benefits of fossil
fuels they don't really understand
energy
so if we look at it from the human
flourishing perspective there is a co2
issue if there was
you know what you want to do is find
every cost-effective means you can
of producing energy with little or no
co2 and the most obvious candidates
would be hydroelectric energy
and nuclear energy because hydroelectric
we can produce that at quite low cost
reliably but it's limited by location so
you can't do it everywhere but where you
can do it
you know if you have a climate crisis or
anything like that not a crisis but even
a problem
that's good notice who is opposing
hydroelectric power the modern
environmental movement they shut down
why it has too much impact on nature so
it's again the anti-impact framework
they'll say like oh it interfered with
the salmon
it's taking up too much space it
interferes with free-flowing rivers and
you think like wait a second
i thought you said the world was going
to end and we can't damn a river
and it just shows you the whole
perspective is about minimizing our
impact it's not really about
worrying about a catastrophe like james
cameron right after he made that avatar
thing which is really about global
warming
like he went down to brazil to stop them
from building a dam
that was his immediate activity and to
him it's one in the same because humans
impacting nature is bad
so i'm going to stop it everywhere i can
and this idea that co2 is going to kill
us all like i think of that as an excuse
for shut for rationalizing stopping
uh stopping our productive impacts on
nature and then nuclear
you know that's the most promising
because that is controllable unlike
solar when it is controllable so you can
rely on it
it can be done anywhere in the world it
has these three amazing properties that
only fossil fuels and nuclear have
so fossil fuels are so cost effective in
large part because they're naturally
concentrated energy they're naturally
stored energy and they're naturally
abundant
so natural forces have taken raw energy
in nature and concentrated into a small
space
stored it so we can deploy it at any
time and given us just an unbelievable
amount like
way more than 10 times all that we used
in all of our history like exists still
in the earth and probably way more than
that
like that's unbelievable and that's why
it's so cost effective because nature
already did all this stuff to make it
pretty convenient and all we have to do
is release the energy
that's sort of true of hydro like nature
brings the evaporation
of water to the top of the river like if
we had to carry the water the top of a
river
of you know of a hydroelectric dam
ourselves it wouldn't work right just
this perpetual motion machine that
wouldn't work
but nature does that and with nuclear
it's even more amazing because
because nature has just harnessed these
unbelievable forces
in the nucleus of an atom and so if you
can release those forces
it's way more concentrated than even oil
like a million times more than oil and
oil is the most concentrated thing we
use in most of our
civilization that's why it's so good for
mobility so it's amazingly concentrated
it's stored and then there's a huge
amount of it so you know
probably tens of thousands or more years
worth of it from if you're talking about
uranium and thorium and even more if you
pulled it from the ocean so like why
aren't we and we know that you know from
history in the u.s
it was pretty cost effective to do very
reliable in the 70s if you had anything
resembling a climate crisis you would be
focused on let's use what we know about
nuclear
and at least do as much electricity as
we can it's harder to do the mobility
and the heat but even with nuclear you
can generate a lot of heat so you should
be able to do that
and with mobility we have nuclear
submarines and aircraft carriers and
icebreakers so
it would be a real crash effort but you
should at least be trying to do that
but who is against nuclear the modern
environmental movement it's not the oil
companies that are stopping nuclear for
the most part
it's the so-called environmentalists and
why what is it
yeah i know you're gonna ask that
because it's again this it's more subtle
but it's again this issue of they impact
nature too much so part of it is it's
viewed as unnatural split the atom
it's just like they talk about radiation
like radiation is bad
radiation's everywhere but if humans
create radiation
it's bad and we just shouldn't be so
it's the human racism again
and particularly when you look at them
talk about the waste it's very revealing
because they say like oh no what about
the waste we can't have this waste and
you think
wait we don't actually have any problems
from nuclear waste we've been generating
it for
generations like it's not nobody is
dying of waste accidents it's actually
fairly easy to store safely it's very
compact
maybe there are better ways of storing
it we can ultimately repurpose it for
fuel but like there's no crisis at all
it's a lot more manageable than solar
waste or wind waste from all that
huge mining involved in those things but
why
why are people against nuclear waste
because it's this there's like we
created this new unnatural material and
it's going to be around for millions of
years
like okay but if it's a pretty stable
material that we can deal with who cares
like that's fine but no
humans have no right to create something
that'll be around for millions of years
so it's again this
anti-humanism if you if you
really cared about rising co2 levels
being a crisis for human life again
hydro and nuclear would be your first
your your obsession you would not
constrain yourself and really castrate
yourself by saying okay we're only going
to use sunlight and wind
and and then batteries which are totally
made from made using fossils like
you would never make that up you would
use what's proven and tested
it's just a total empirical fact that
there is nowhere in the world
that runs on anything resembling solar
wind and batteries there's just nothing
that does that whatsoever i don't know
if you saw this but i've gotten in this
little
with elon musk like whom i really i was
listening to an interview of yours with
um
what was her name like polina pompliano
or something like she's i
love elon musk in a lot of ways so i
like i was i started listening to that
because i'm really interested in him
he's a really brilliant guy
but he really misrepresents the uh
scalability of what he does and so he
said this thing about
oh all you need to power the world and
you can see this on twitter.com
alexefton if you watch this in the near
future it'll be you know the time
like oh you can power the whole world on
solar
plus some batteries that's what he said
so i ran the numbers at his best cost
that he's provided for the batteries
and yeah for those batteries that you
need to back up solar for three days
which is pretty conservative if you need
to run the whole world on solar
and you know sometimes in different
areas you don't have much sunlight like
yeah it has 400 trillion dollars
so 400 trillion dollars is like six and
a half times global gdp
that's just for batteries mind you
that's not like all these other things
and
so this is nobody is doing this it's a
total
it's worse than a fantasy and yet people
really think
that you can put solar panels wind
turbines and batteries together and
that's some amazing thing
and it's actually going to work even for
electricity let alone for industrial
heat
let alone for uh heavy duty mobility
where
we don't have these electric planes or
even hydra like we're talking about
destroying our whole energy system for
things that have never existed
and many of which are not close to
existing and the entire world is bought
into this everyone is saying carbon
neutral net zero
by 2050 and we're trying to do it while
we still
criminalize and demonize nuclear and
we're stopping hydro all over the place
if that is not a religious cult
i don't know what it is what about the
problems of
risks with nuclear spills and
explosions and danger
yeah i mean i'm laughing and not not
because i think it's it's an innocent
question but it's not innocent that it
is a question for the public
because the fact about nuclear is the
safest source of energy
ever created and for a fairly obvious
physical reason
which is that it cannot explode so of
course a nuclear bomb can explode
that deals with a totally different type
of uranium than exists in a nuclear
power plant
the best comment ever by one of my
energy heroes a guy named
peter beckman who's unfortunately
deceased you know somebody said
like hey what happens if we blow up a
nuclear power plant if terrorists blow
it up isn't that going to be a disaster
and he said if a terrorist blows up a
nuclear power plant
they should win a nobel prize because
they'll have discovered a law of physics
that doesn't exist but chernobyl blew up
no no it's not it's not blowing up
atomically no
right well that's very important though
because people are associated
so chernobyl is also interesting because
well so essentially chernobyl is the
only case
where you have any deaths due to
radiation which is pretty astonishing
there's only one case
in all of it and so what's interesting
is it involved
a type of reactor that was sort of a
hybrid uh
energy producing reactor but also sort
of like a weapon that was never tried or
considered in any civilized part of the
world so it's like
you can call it nuclear but it's not the
same thing it's just like ever you can
call
everything chemical in a sense but there
are certain types of uses of chemicals
that are totally benign
and that can't do things so what what
they tried in chernobyl was not even
considered let alone tried where we were
and couldn't have been
and even and on top of that and related
to that it was in the soviet union which
is one of my favorite economies
economists pointed out like everything
in the soviet union was deadly
like imagine how many deaths there were
from soviet toasters
like a hell of a lot more than chernobyl
so so chernobyl you have a couple dozen
documented deaths you have certain like
treatable conditions and that was you
know
that was a disaster but that shows you
like even we have a total disaster
by one of the worst regimes in history
using something civilized countries
would never consider or allow
even then it's limited in its
destructive potential so we should be
thinking about nuclear like nuclear is
the safest form of energy
uh ever there's like solar panels you
know solar panels
the main problems are not very good at
producing energy reliably at low cost
but you can have solar panels have all
sorts of issues like if you have your
if you know it catches on fire and the
stun and the sun is still shining there
are all sorts of problems where fire
departments can't
deal with these houses because what you
have you have this electrical power
plant
on the roof of your house right and it's
connected to batteries
and so it can be hard to shut off and
you have all these issues with fires i
mean
and you know there are different ways of
dealing this you have wind turbines that
catch on fire and go out of control
you have all the deaths involved in the
mining for those things now i don't
think solar wind are particularly
dangerous but empirically they are more
dangerous
than nuclear the main thing oh yeah it's
the main thing that's dangerous about
them though
is that they don't provide energy so my
my basic
the most dangerous thing is being
useless yeah but that is
really important like not no energy
is more dangerous than no energy
because then you have to live in nature
i saw a video on twitter a while ago
and it was an animation of this huge
sort of gollum
looking creature stopping a a big
boulder rolling down a hill
and it's symbolic of nuclear energy have
you seen this
no i'll try and get if i can find it
i'll make video guiding put it over the
video here
um basically it's just it's just a
suggestion that
um chernobyl and fukushima
were reason enough
and sufficiently public to cause a
cascading effect that nuclear is now
essentially out of the window by people
that
perhaps no less than they claim to know
yeah perhaps fukushima i think is a
perfect
kind of of revelation because if you
look at the situation like
what do most people associate fukushima
with what do they associate that
situation with they associate it with
like a failure of a nuclear power plant
yeah what happened is what a tsunami
kills 20 000 people
you are actually a lot safer if you were
in the nuclear power plant well you
really nobody
of course it's one of the safest places
in the world i mean imagine 9 11
they tried to crash in a nuclear power
plant like just the people in the plane
would have died which had been
incredibly tragic but it wouldn't have
been like
like this whole terrorist thing like
look at what people can do with an
airplane in a building
like that nuclear has nowhere near
that potential again we're talking about
a providing energy which is crucial
to human beings living a modern life and
b we're talking about these concerns
that
rising co2 levels are an existential
threat and people
still will just will believe in or more
importantly propagate
these just totally erroneous notions
about nuclear so
yeah the fukushima thing is 20 000
people die from a tsunami
no one dies from radiation and how do we
characterize it it's like oh nuclear is
dangerous no nature is dangerous
nuclear is safe and of course when japan
shuts down all those reactors and they
didn't even like to say okay maybe we
shouldn't have built it in this
particular place
it's this shows also the religious
nature how nuclear is put as this
universal package so it's like oh
chernobyl all these places we shouldn't
explore anything that involves splitting
the atom what could be more
unscientific than saying we're not going
to explore nuclear physics at all
anything that involves that advanced
knowledge and skill we're just going to
put off and definitely
all we are willing to do is to try to
turn sunlight and wind gusts into energy
that's what we're going to limit it
to like this is crazy why can't we do
that why can't we use solar and wind
well i mean we did for thousands of
years and it was very bad
um i mean the percentage of renewable
energy has decreased over time
what is it is it not not point three
no no i it's not know it's i'm not sure
what that language means not point three
percent
what's the current percentage of global
energy output created by renewables
well so renewables is another kind of
vague package so if solar because
i promise i'm not purposefully trying to
use
i keep on stepping on different
landmines of that have been let down by
other people
no no i i'm sorry and i didn't mean it
at all personally i just meant that
that's it's this is the terminology so
yeah renewable because it
it can renewable there's this question
does it include hydro
and does it include burning wood so
people usually
and the renewable movement is mostly
anti-hydro
and actually a lot of like the majority
or at least the most renewable in europe
is actually burning wood and which
people don't know
often like we chop down trees in the u.s
using oil-powered chainsaws then
transport them using oil-powered cargo
ships
oh we chop them up probably using
natural gas or coal
into these little wood pellets and then
we stick them in a plant in germany
and it's called carbon uh neutral so
that's like a real process that's
happening and there's a question of like
why is this happening
and it goes to why don't we use solar
wind it's because
they're not controllable or reliable
sources of energy so i mentioned that
with fossil fuels in nuclear and to some
extent hydra you have this phenomenon of
nature concentrates and stores huge
amounts of energy for you
and you just have to release them and so
that's what makes it so cost-effective
that nature's already done this work if
you have to concentrate and store the
energy yourself
then you have to make all these machines
and use all these resources to do it
and with solar and wind the biggest
problem is effectively storing them is
is storing enough of them so that you
always have energy
when you need it and it's so non-cost
effective that nobody does anything
close to this anywhere except for people
using very low energy kind of off-grid
but they're not producing anything
significant
they're kind of living a low consumption
lifestyle and even that lifestyle all
the equipment is produced using fossil
fuels or nuclear it's not made using
solar panels
uh and and wind turbines so this what's
happened unfortunately though
is in the the field of electricity in
particular
is that to promote the idea that solar
and wind
and batteries are viable instead of
actually creating independent systems or
power plants that can meet normal
standards of reliability like if they
did that that would be great i'd be
happy to see that
instead what they do is they take the
existing electric grid
with all of these controllable reliable
sources of energy
nuclear coal and most importantly
natural gas because natural gas can
easily cycle up and down
to adapt to changes and so they stick
solar and wind on those
and then what happens is the natural gas
is constantly adjusting to them so when
the sun shines the natural gas goes down
when the sun fades the natural gas goes
up the same thing with the wind blowing
etc etc batteries are so expensive that
they're just a tiny tiny percentage like
in texas
when we have these disasters is
something like 40 seconds worth of
energy and
even something like that at 40 of that
was lost so it's just nothing right
batteries are a trivial
thing whatever uh musk talks about so
the real thing that happens is solar and
wind are parasites
on the grid today and if you think
logically like
is it is it going to be more cost
effective to have
all these reliable power plants uh
that and then add on all these
unreliable power plants plus unreliable
infrastructure or is it going to be
cheaper to just have the reliable power
plants and it's way cheaper to just have
the reliable power plants
because you need to build almost as many
of them if you have the unreliables
because the unreliables can almost
always go near zero
so you always need to have 100 reliable
plus all that's unreliable
plus this infrastructure plus the
reliables operate
really inefficiently when you cycle them
up and down it's like stop and go
traffic
so it's really this mess which is why
everywhere these unreliables are used
the price of electricity goes up and yet
we hear all this reporting about how it
goes down
and this is all just energy accounting
fraud what they do is they don't look at
the full system costs of solar and wind
they'll say just look at the price of
solar panels or just look at some price
in isolation but over and over we see
that the more these things are used
the more prices go up like germany pays
three times what the u.s pays the u.s
pays way more than we should pay
coal and particularly gas prices have
gone down and yet electricity prices
have gone up
there aren't too many candidates we
haven't been building a lot of new
nuclear plants that are expensive it's
because the solar and wind
have added cost and then the other
problem is once they add
cost people try to cut costs and where
do they cut costs they shut down
reliable power plants
or they defund resiliency so you see
this in texas
where they defunded you know
weatherizing plants that could be more
durable
all sorts of places around the world
deal with coal and gas deal with much
lower temperatures in texas had no
problem
but texas did not have the same
resiliency they also didn't even have
enough reliable power
online even if everything had worked
perfectly to not have significant
blackouts because they've spent at least
66 billion dollars
on solar wind and that comes from other
places so you try to cut down on the
reliables
you play what i call reliability chicken
and the biggest offender is
unfortunately where i live in california
i'm the biggest offender in the u.s
because that's what we that's why we had
big blackouts last summer
and we why we've been in danger because
we're trying to shut down as many
reliable power plants as we can
including nuclear plants by the way
which is doubly insane
and we're trying to rely on our solar
and wind but we're really relying on
out-of-state power from arizona
uh from utah from nevada but the problem
is they're trying to have more
unreliable energy too
so everyone is trying to play
unreliability chicken and they're
relying
on reliables like just one example is in
la i posted something on twitter last
year
like at one point they were getting at
least 40 of their electricity from coal
i believe mostly from utah so it's not
in california right we don't have any
coal in california
but we're getting coal turned into
electricity and delivered to california
but the more that this is it's just it's
this parasite game
and so the reason i'm going into this is
because i know everyone is going to hear
these claims of solar and wind or cheap
etc and it's all what i call
accounting fraud or partial cost
accounting there is the important thing
is there is
no standalone solar wind battery thing
that anybody uses anywhere because it's
so cost prohibitive and so if anyone
thinks it's a good idea they should
prove it
in reality by creating like apple if
they're going to be 100 renewable great
create your own installation but instead
what they do is they plug into the grid
they parasite on coal and gas and
nuclear
and then they sometimes add a bunch of
unreliable solar wind and they say hey
look we ran on all the solar and wind
and you guys used all the coal but
that's not how it works physically
that's like
the analogy is like if you take a
sailboat if you take a diesel-powered
boat across the ocean
and you put a sail on it and the sail
gives it 10 of its energy you as tim
cook don't get to say i got there on the
sale
and the rest of you guys got there on
the diesel that's what apple is doing
when they say they're 100
renewable it seems to me one of the
biggest things
that is a blindness for most people and
myself before reading your book
to do with thinking towards the future
is the misunderstanding of the fact that
energy permits technology advancement
and future technology can fix many of
the problems that the energy consumption
is going to cause in the present
is that a fair way to frame it i think
it's a it's a very good way to frame it
i mean
it it does it in the future and in the
present so i focused a bit on the
present because even if you think about
like climate
it's very important that climate-related
disaster deaths are down 98
over the last century like nobody talks
about this just to show you how biased
the system is
the un ipcc which has some that's called
the intergovernmental plan on climate
change like you look at all their
reports it's all about
how we're endangering climate they never
mention
climate-related deaths or
climate-related disasters that's going
way down
that is like i mean how could you that's
like you're doing a report on like
malaria
like malaria decreased by 98 and you
were studying like a malaria crisis
like you would need to point out that
it's been decreasing so it
but nobody even talks about this so we
have this blindness because we
we have this belief that it's wrong to
impact the climate that it's got to be
self-destructive so we don't even
look at the numbers we don't even notice
hey wait haven't we developed all these
good technologies for protecting
ourselves from climate like
building homes and heating and air
conditioning and like drought relief is
the most amazing
because drought could kill millions of
people
in the past i mean you look i have some
headlines in my next book fossil future
which um
it's not out now you can't even get on
amazon by the way i just sorry one note
to interrupt
this is a temporary thing but do not buy
the revised moral
case for fossil fuels on amazon because
it's a fake book so don't do that no
way who's done that no no it's it's not
it's not anyone screwing me it's just
they messed up it was
basically my book fossil future was
originally conceived as a revision and
then i ended up writing a whole new book
but still on amazon it says revised and
so it just it kills me that people are
buying that book
and it's not going to get delivered so
i'll find the correct link and it will
be in the show notes below
yeah just more with the one with the
blue cover the the bright blue cover
that i sent you
that's that's fine so sorry for for that
but it's just it's been bothering me
uh lately so where did we of course i
interrupted myself talking about
technology the future of technology
you're talking about drought yeah
drought drought is like
these stories about you know just
reading about places like china and just
millions of people dying from these dr
it's just so
so tragic to think about what people
living in like a more natural world
without modern technology what that's
like
and now we have you know modern
irrigation a lot of which is high energy
and we have drought relief convoys where
you can give
you know food to people who can't grow
food and you know drought related deaths
now go down to like the level of a
thousand a year
it's just this unbelievable thing nobody
talks about like
drought we're so good at mastering
drought that i have never heard anyone
explain any possible situation that
could actually be a drought
problem globally also interestingly it's
true for wildfires now that seems
impossible given what we've seen in
australia in california
but if you look at like what we have at
our disposal in terms of modern fire
management
in terms of if you actually thin the
forests if you don't allow these huge
fuel loads to build up
if you build barriers like there's no
conceivable scenario where fires could
be a big problem it's all this man-made
stuff
that actually comes from this whole
anti-impact approach where we say
we're not allowed to clear the brush
we're not allowed to control burn
controlled burns we're not allowed
to do logging and so we basically treat
create we make the forest a bomb
but that's it that's not like if the
temperature rose three or four degrees
and we manage the forest properly
we would not have a a problem with fires
at all so
it's actually really hard to think of
anything that even today's capabilities
can't deal with
let alone tomorrow's i mean the most
plausible is like a super rapid sea
level rise
so if you talk about like multiple feet
per decade which al gore makes us
think is going to happen because he
talks about 20 feet in his movie and
he's not very clear about when that's
going to happen
but you know that what we've been
experiencing is like a foot a century
and then
you know cut some of the high
predictions are like three feet
in a century that is not even a problem
for today's levels
let alone imagine if sea levels were
rising and we had an issue imagine how
many like smart people
could help us deal with that we already
have a hundred plus million people
living
below sea level now so once you start to
really think in a pro-human
pro-technology way about climate you
don't think of it as this religious
thing that
oh it was perfect and it's wrong if we
impact if you just think of it as hey
here's another factor that we want to
deal with constructively
it's really hard to think of anything
that could be like a big
problem with what we have today let
alone um the future
and this is controversial but in the
future we will also learn how to improve
climate
um i mean that's that's that's that's
sacrilege which shows you that it's a
religious kind of thing but like
as this guy points out in this really
good book where's my i think it's called
where's my flying car by this guy named
jay storz hall a really good book
like he points out imagine how much
people would pay to make their climate
like california's climate
which i i'm lucky enough to live in
california like that would be so much
value
people are going to figure out how to do
that and that just goes to show that our
if we also if you wanted to you can i
believe
fairly safely reduce the amount of
sunlight coming to the u.s
like you can sort of mimic what a
volcano has done like we know that
volcanoes in the past have cooled the
earth
like you could test that out and mimic
it i believe in a safe way i'm not in
favor of it now because i don't think
it's necessary
but this idea that we're just we face an
existential threat from warming and all
we can do
is just outlaw all the fossil fuels and
mandate unreliable solar wind i just
want to stress it's a religious
perspective it's not a scientific
perspective
none of it makes any sense i think we
should be using more fossil fuels but
even if we weren't we should be using
nuclear we should be looking at
technological ways to deal with it
and we should recognize that the biggest
problem in the world
is lack of energy for billions of people
not
one or two or three degrees warmer
you've hit one of the tripwires that
i've laid around this conversation you
just said existential risk there
what are your thoughts on extinction
rebellion
i mean it's i don't know how many people
even know about them i mean
i know in in the uk they're very very
well known yeah i mean have you seen
did you see them smashing the windows or
was it barclays or santanders
headquarters do you see this
i see some of it i mean it like i'm very
kind of u.s
focused yeah yeah yeah yeah follow some
dudes people i've never seen someone
smash a window in a less cool way that
they literally can't smash windows in a
cool way
you swing a thing at a big thing and it
makes a big crack but no no no no
they've arrived with this sort of mallet
and chisel and
with their masks on and a pink beanie
doing all of the four corners
what do you do what are you trying to
demonstrate is this wanton destruction
of glass which presumably is going to
need fossil fuels to then
re-deliver the glass bag to fix it or
are you enacting some sort of rage
because if that's your rage
i'm not tremendously scared of it but
yeah so i have a big problem with
extinction rebellion right
and it's because i'm a big fan of
existential risk
have you read toby odds the precipice no
oh dude
alex let me let me i'll tell you once
we're done everyone that's listening has
already heard me talk about it a million
times um
basically toby toby runs mathematical
models he's a philosopher from the
future of humanities institute
in oxford which is the number one
existential risk research lab
basically in the world and he runs the
numbers
the likelihood of us going extinct
humans
existential risk so a um
global irreversible neutering of our
capacity to reach our full potential as
a civilization
is roughly the definition he uses of
existential risk
and he notes them all down and he has
the natural risks and then he has the
anthropogenic risks as well
over the next century the likelihood
that climate change is an existential
risk to us is one
in ten thousand the likelihood of
super intelligent artificial general
intelligence that's misaligned
is one in ten
natural pandemics one in thirty
engineered pandemics one in
a hundred super volcanoes one in a
million
gamma ray bursts one in a billion et
cetera et cetera it pales
in comparison and this sort of leads me
to the problem i have with extinction
rebellion which is
whose extinction are you bothered about
genuinely
what is the extinction that you're
concerned about it should be existential
risk rebellion
if it was that and they were looking at
the actual statistics around what is the
most likely thing
to cause humans to go extinct that's the
question that presumably they're talking
about
but it gets all conflated with this sort
of naturalistic
human racism and well it's not just
about that it's
the animals shouldn't be going extinct
either okay cool
do you know that we need to be able to
develop technology to save
animals and ourselves from the non-zero
number of natural
background risks that occur so if we
were to continue let's say that we
ceased all technological progress now
and just went back to being
nomads the human race won't leave the
planet
we won't go to mars we will die because
there is a non-zero
existential risk number in the
background whether that be engineered
pandemics or natural pandemics or it
wouldn't be engineered because those
those labs would have been shut natural
pandemics super volcanoes whatever it
might be asteroids right so we need
technology to protect ourselves
we're also the lions aren't going to do
it for us so if we stop doing it
they're all dead every animal on the
earth will die
eventually even if you want to roll the
clock forward a little bit more whatever
it is 2 billion years
the sun's going to expand and the earth
is going to be gone if you want to save
the maximum number of future potential
lives both human
and in terms of the animals the best
thing that we can do
is focus our attention on to not [ __ ]
up
the big risks that we have over the next
century one in ten
is the likelihood that toby or the in
the epicenter
of existential risk research puts on
artificial general intelligence being
the thing that we could
it's the number one risk right the
number one risk
i mean i don't i don't believe there's
numbers at all but i i
i agree with a lot of the thrust of what
you're you're talking about i mean
you know one way to think of it you can
think of technology and progress from
the perspective of like
what is human being what are our
capabilities
and all things being equal you know you
want more capabilities
going forward to deal with a wide
variety of things so when i was
drafting fossil futures i was writing a
part of it this was before
coven and i was noted i was noting like
hey here are the things i'm really
concerned about
you know and and i wish i had said oh
like you know a pandemic from a flu-like
but more extreme
i didn't say that but antibiotic
resistance is definitely one that i and
it's not like existentialism everyone's
gonna die but
like that is a real there's a real thing
that you can see
it's the antibiotics are amazing but
they have these side effects and you see
resistance and like
the more capable you are as a
civilization
like the more you can kind of deal with
anything so it
it's a very high burden of proof to show
we should focus all
on dealing with one thing particularly
if it has any chance let alone i believe
a certainty of neutering
our capabilities so if it's like let's
stop using energy
like let's let's make energy more
expensive and less reliable
so that we can sort of make nature more
friendly to us in this one
respect like it our whole so i mentioned
before like
everything in our society depends it's
like it's a machine
it's produced by a machine or it's
produced by the time human time freed up
by machines you think about we want
millions of people if there's a pandemic
to be able to think about it and deal
with it and
and help us treat it like that's only
possible with the machine labor
civilization so in general i totally
agree that the more
capabilities we the more freedom you
have and the more ability you have to
to make progress the more you can deal
with any of these
kinds of things and so that it's notable
that often the anti-technology
the people concerned about technologies
you can say like there's one of two ways
to deal with it
if you think there's a real threat you
can say okay let's let's sort of evolve
and figure out how to deal with the
threat
or let's just withdraw technology and in
general there's a very strong attitude
of let's
withdraw technology and it's such a bad
attitude and it's also a completely
impractical attitude because you cannot
control the rest of the world like
correct if you look at fossil fuels i've
been writing a lot about china
like we are such useful idiots
with regard to china like china is using
more and more coal like in 2020
you know they have record 2020 pandemic
here mind you
like record oil imports they have um
three texas worth of coal plants but new
coal plants
uh under development like all these
different markers of more and more
fossil fuels and china
is there like the productive center of
the whole world like we in the us you
and the uk
you're using china so we're all using
chinese coal whether we
think about it or not there's no chance
that china is going to stop using fossil
fuels
so long as it's the most cost-effective
way for them to do things and we are
totally delusional about this and so
even if you thought yeah co2 is a big
issue like you have to look for truly
technological means of dealing with it
which either means you find a way like
to capture the co2 which is
a total [ __ ] which i i don't think is
very promising at all but people can try
to do that
um you can try to figure out how to cool
the planet which i think if
there was a real problem that's where
you would focus your energies or you can
try to develop
like non-carbon alternatives including
nuclear
uh which as i said people should we
should do that anyway we should focus on
that anyway
uh but that is that that does take a
long time that's like a
multi-generational
thing but this idea that we're going to
stop like this idea that oh we're going
to make our own sacrifices and pledges
and then china is going to go along with
it it's just another example of like
you cannot hold back 8 billion people
from making progress you just better
make the best progress you can including
to counter
the problems that the progress causes
this is a justification for a
totalitarian state if ever i've heard
one
all of these people with their freedom
to talk their freedom to post and tweet
whatever they want and do research
north korea north korea can use as much
fossil fuels as they want or
china they can use them all it's it is
interesting when you think about it
a very broad sort of civilizational
perspective you're going to see a power
swing
i i wonder if neutering is the word that
i always use i wonder how much
progress is being muted in the west by
a focus on technologies which are
inherently less efficient
which inherently slow down our capacity
to be able to move forward and to keep
up with
the east and china are
a terrifying force at the moment and
that's only going to get worse if you
decide to strap one of our hands behind
our backs
yeah it's it's really i've become i'm
surprised i wasn't more interested in
this before i've become really
interested in the last six or nine
months
it's i mean there are some things that
reassure me just because not a free
country so that
gives it a lot of of impediments but
it's really scary that this sort of
totalitarian anti-fossil fuel movement
because it has a totalitarian quality
like we're going to abolish this
and it always involves imposing these
new green energy things like
like joe biden is going to tell us how
to do it so it has this whole
like so-called central planning uh
government control to it which is just
it's a disaster on its own and then
you're mandating these religiously
preferred
like unreliable technologies so it is
scary to think of the freer countries in
general
becoming the least free with regard to
energy because that's the industry that
powers every other industry
so that's your economy and it's also
your security like the us is only as
secure as we are
because we have such a productive
economy that can you know that can
keep us secure by manufacturing these
weapons and stuff
and then also so we're neutering like
our fundamental industry
and we're actually like exporting it to
china so we're having
the chinese use fossil fuels
to make us our unreliable energy like
they're making the solar panels and wind
turbines and then using fossil fuels
and then that's such a and then also
like there's the whole issue of stealing
all the patents
and like that's that's totally okay
because you know one of the issues with
a place like china is innovation
but if you allow people to steal all of
your innovations like once you have the
innovation and
there's a you know you have prototypes
of things then that can be copied and we
know that this regime has an explicit
goal of world domination
or at least you know being the world
superpower by 2049 and so the
i really think i just think about what
are the chinese dictators thinking when
they see the us
in the eu i mean my private joke is like
i think of it as like useful idiots or
like us full idiots and eu's full idiots
you know for the us
and the eu because it's you just it's
one of these scary things that you feel
like you see
like you look at the past you're like
okay you got to do something about this
hitler guy right like
he is rising like this is not going to
go well
and it's like oh yeah chamberlain you
make a deal with him yet that's really
going to work right he's going to be
totally satisfied and he'll just
hang out with his mistress all the time
and be like no he's not going to be a
piece and you just think like china's on
this clear trajectory
and we fit it into it perfectly by
buying unreliable energy gutting our own
capabilities
and then praising them i mean like i
don't want to pick on elon
too much but like he was like i'm so
impressed with china's
efforts toward carbon neutrality larry
fink the most powerful man in the
financial world head of black rock he's
like
in his annual letter to ceos which is
incredibly influential
he talked about like he his only mention
of china and talking about how we're
going to become carbon neutrals
china made like an inspiring commitment
to be carbon neutral
and i tweeted about this like this is
the same year they're using record oil
imports like
five-year high of coal production all
these
it's just the idiocy it's this blindness
dangerous man
it's really really dangerous i mean it's
dangerous i mean it's always
you know nothing's more dangerous than
no energy except no energy
and a highly energized ambitious uh
enemy
god yeah i am
the useful idiots thing is interesting
douglas murray had this quote where he
said when the barbarians are at the door
we'll be debating about what gender they
are
and the equivalent here is when the
barbarians are at the door
we'll be asking whether or not they're
going to knock our door down with green
energy fueled cars or not
like that that's that's how it is when
you saw the capitol hill riots
right when you saw that occurring russia
and china must have been thinking i
don't know whether how much influence
they had on it or not
probably more than most people know
because it seems like they always just
have more influence on
all of the [ __ ] that goes on than most
people know but they must have just even
if they weren't they must have been
sitting
thinking i can't believe it they're
tearing themselves apart we don't have
to do anything here
they are literally tearing themselves
apart internally and
as much as i love a democracy and i want
capitalism and personal sovereignty and
meritocracy everyone can be whatever
they want to be
i don't know i i wonder how long do you
let
a world power with defined objectives to
take over the globe
how long do you allow them to keep going
forward
before you say right okay sort of the
children that want to debate amongst
themselves
in the eu and in america that we need to
have some more
forceful or restricted choices in terms
of how public policies run because
allowing the public to vote appears to
be getting us
in a direction that's actually neutering
our capacity do you know what i mean
i'm not i'm not i'm not advocating for a
totalitarian state here but
if the consensus
amongst the electorate is so
far away from what is optimal for the
country
and perhaps the world at large how long
do you allow that to go on for
well there's a question of who because i
think certainly in america and probably
probably in europe as well you know the
intellectuals are generally worse
so the you know the when i'm in terms of
the intellectual elite
of the society you know you can think of
them as the thought leaders or sometimes
call them the designated experts like
these are the people certainly on energy
and environmental issues
um like these are the people pushing for
net
zero like if you look at the average
american when they're polled and they
say
you know there are these studies the
effect of like how much would you do you
care about climate change
yes how much would you pay per month to
deal do
deal with climate change like less than
ten dollars
like i actually think that's pretty
rational in terms of just like there's a
sort of common sense yeah this is kind
of something i care about but it's
pretty remote and the world is not
ending and people have been kind of
talking about this a long time and
like i really need that ten dollars and
people really do need their money it's
you know most people don't have very
much of it and there's a lot that we
need to do
like versus these these uh
the leaders which i'm really calling the
useful idiots which is they're like
they're
totally willing to just risk the entire
civilization
on this idea like just think about the
net zero thing
even just there's no concern that it
might not work as implemented i
say there's no evidence it could work in
any way but like you just think about
how badly like your average amtrak
that's
trained in the us like how bad like a
rail project is
and they're making all these plans for
like trillions of dollars
and we already see what's happening in
places like texas and california with
relatively small amounts of unreliables
like there's not even a concern that we
might do this the wrong way that's how
drunk people are on this goal of
eliminating our impact particularly
eliminating our climate impact
and then the specific means of what they
would call renewable what i'd call
unreliable energy so i think you don't
really have it's really the leaders
and that's that's the that's the scary
thing because if we're just oh the
leaders are wise
and then the people are just on this
terrible track but it's more like no
that the people are finally
catching up to the leaders or i think
with you know biden and trump what we
had is
there were so many issues about them
that were not related to this issue of
energy
like i think it's very plausible that
somebody who wasn't trump and didn't
have a bunch of issues
associated with him could have beaten
biden and then we the us wouldn't be
going in this
uh kind of direction but it's at least
to the point where what biden is
proposing doesn't strike most people as
oh yeah that's going to destroy our
country
it's like oh yeah that sounds like kind
of an interesting idea i've i've heard
that tesla's
you know apple is all solar and wind and
tesla is all solar and so
that shouldn't be too hard that
shouldn't disrupt my life very much
versus
no what you experience in texas is like
a is a dream
compared to what we would experience if
these policies actually existed
cataclysmic i love it alex man thank you
for coming on the moral case for fossil
fuels the correct one will be linked in
the show notes below
if people want to do a little bit more
digging or further educate themselves
where should they go
thanks for asking so i put up a website
called energytalkingpoints.com
and that sort of breaks down every issue
you can imagine
and in very sort of bite-sized and
well-referenced chunks i definitely say
check out energytalkingpoints.com
and if you want to be on my mailing list
i send out one email a week with just
the latest stuff that's going on
alexepsteinlist.com and then i'm on
twitter.com
alex epstein perfect man thank you very
much good luck with the new book as well
thank you thank you very much for tuning
in if you enjoyed that
then press here for a selection of the
best clips
from the podcast over the last few
months and don't forget to subscribe
it makes me very happy indeed peace